[Music]
parla fluency is hitting every corner
though new radical extreme Democratic
Party look at the city of San Francisco
handling the pandemic they gave it out
free drugs and alcohol and weed and
cigarettes to homeless people to help
them stay quarantine congressman Acacio
Cortez she's outraged or fainting it
slamming JetBlue they did a New York
City flyover honoring first responders
and frontline healthcare workers
tweeting out nothing like a corporate PR
campaign the birds jet fuel at low
altitudes over vulnerable communities
dying from a respiratory virus
congresswoman one of us Nancy Pelosi how
she goes back and forth from San
Francisco and whether or not she uses a
private jet ask her that here with
reaction author of don't burn this book
dave rubin salem nationally syndicated
radio host larry elder mister rubin
really weed booze cigarettes maybe i
want to be homeless cuz i probably could
use all of them at this point not that i
use drugs Sean they're really onto
something up there I mean let me get
this straight so you can get drunk then
you can get stoned then you get the
munchies then you swing on over to
Pelosi z-- for some ice cream I mean I
think San Francisco I've got some sort
of new a comic thing working out right
now but the whole things of course it's
nuts look my good friend Larry elder and
I were here in Los Angeles I mean quite
literally I can't bring a bottle of wine
to Larry's house house and us have a
drink but we're gonna give booze and
weed to homeless people I'm not even
against booze and weed okay but it's
just great this is just typical San
Francisco stuff Larry I don't think I
could have made this up you you really
can't but this is California Sean this
is this is a one-party state there isn't
a single Republican who holds an office
statewide they've got majorities not
just majorities in both houses of the
legislature Sean
they've got super majorities this is a
town that gives a state
gives illegal aliens in-state tuition
something that your kid couldn't get if
your kid got into UCLA or USC so why
should anybody be surprised you can
defecate in the streets and in
California as long as you're not
touching clutching a bunch of banned
plastic straws you're good to go make
sure you're wearing your face mask while
you're doing it
yeah all right so what happens you just
get online how do you get your free weed
booze and and cigarettes that mist Dave
how do we do that well I love that I
love that concept it's like do you have
to prove you're homeless somehow I mean
I thought these are the same people that
are against IDs how do you prove you're
homeless so you can show up to get the
weed and the booze I mean none of it
makes sense but it's so consistent with
progressive policies I mean look Gavin
Newsom who's our governor here I mean
elder we got to get out of here can we
talk after the show we got to get out of
this you guys gotta get out of there
woman we shouldn't be surprised I've got
to get out of oh let's send the co-ed
patients to nursing homes to infect
everybody that's vulnerable that's the
state I live in Larry last word
absolutely this is where we are my
two-step solution to save California
Shawn keep the illegal aliens deport the
Democrats all right go run thank you
both Congrats on the book Dave as well
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell